maybe another interesting
person to talk about is ernest becker
himself sure
so how did he face his
death is there something interesting
personal i think so so uh
interesting to me is um
becker also from a jewish family
claimed to be atheistic
uh did not identify
ultimately as jewish i believe he
converted
to christianity but was himself
a religious person and he said he became
religious
when his first child was born now
religious
what does that mean does he have a faith
and well let's talk more most
importantly is the afterlife
he was his view on the afterlife he was
uh agnostic
on that but he did um now
the denial of death is
um there's a chapter devoted to
kierkegaard
and he talks about
for kierkegaard um if you want to become
a mature individual you know if you want
to learn something you go to
the university if you want to become a
more
mature individual according to
kierkegaard you got to go to the unit
you got to go to the school of anxiety
and what kierkegaard said is that we
have to let this
vague dis ease put a hyphen between
dis and ease about death
kierkegaard's point is you have to
really think about that you have to
think about it and
feel it you gotta let it seek in or seep
into your mind
at which point according to kierkegaard
basically you realize
that your present identity is
fundamentally a cultural construction
you didn't choose the time and place of
your birth you didn't choose your name
uh you know you didn't choose
necessarily
even the social role that you occupy you
might have chosen
from what's available in your culture
but not from the full palette
of human opportunities and so what
kierkegaard said is that
we need to realize that
we've been living a lie of sorts
becker calls it a necessary lie
and and we have to momentarily
dispose of that and so now kierkegaard
says well here i am
i i have shrugged off uh
all of the cultural accoutrements that i
have used
uh to define myself
and now what am i or who am i this is
like the ancient greek tragedy where the
worst thing was to be
no one or no thing
all right at this point kierkegaard said
you're really dangling on the precipice
of oblivion and some people tumble into
that abyss
and never come out on the other hand
kierkegaard said that what you can now
do metaphorically and literally is to
rebuild yourself from the ground up
and there's a in the new testament
there's something you have to die in
order to be reborn
and kierkegaard's view though is that
there's only one way to do that this is
his proverbial
leap into faith and in kierkegaard's
case it was faith and christianity
that you can't have unbridled faith and
cultural constructions
the only thing that you can have
unequivocal
faith in is some kind of transcendent
power all right but of course
this raises the question of well is that
just another death-denying belief system
right and at the end of the denial of
death
becker admits that there's no way to
tell
while still advocating for what is
ultimately a religious stance
now one of the things that i don't
understand and i
becker has been the the most singularly
potent influence
in my academic and personal life but a
year or two ago
i i um started reading uh martin
heidegger
i'm reading being in time and
what i now wonder is why
um why becker who refers to heidegger
from time to time in his work
why he didn't take heidegger more
seriously because heidegger
has this is like a secular kierkegaard
he's he has the same thing which is
death anxiety
oh and i should have pointed out that
what kierkegaard says is that
death anxiety most people don't go to
the school of anxiety
they flee from death anxiety
by embracing their cultural beliefs
kierkegaard says they then tranquilize
themselves with the trivial
and i love that phrase it's a beautiful
phrase because at the end of the denial
of death becker's like look the average
american
is either drinking or shopping or
watching television and
they're all the same thing right
heidegger says the same thing
he says look and he acknowledges
kierkegaard he says
what makes us feel unsettled
and evidently that's an english
translation of angst
that that it's we don't feel at home
in the world heidegger says that's
death anxiety and one direction
is the the kierkegaard one he heidegger
calls it a flight from death
you just unself reflexively cling to
your cultural constructions
and heidegger borrows the term
tranquilized but he points out that
he doesn't care for that term because
tranquilized
sounds like you're subdued when in fact
what most
culturally constructed meat puppets do
is to be
frenetically engaged with their
surroundings to ensure that they never
sit still long enough
to actually think about anything
consequential
heidegger says there's another way
though he's like yo
what you can do is to come to terms with
that death anxiety
in the following way thing number one
is to realize that not only
are you going to die but your death can
happen at any given moment
so for heidegger if you say i know i'm
gonna die in some vaguely unspecified
future moment
that's still death denial because you're
saying yeah
not me not now yeah heidegger's point is
you need to get to the point uh where
you need to realize that uh you know i
need to realize
that i can walk outside and
get smote by a comet or i can stop for
gas on the way home and
catch the virus and be dead in two days
there were any number
of potentially unanticipated and
uncontrollable fatal outcomes but
by the way sorry uh to to bring into the
now
yeah the stuff it is brilliant i i agree
lex and this is why
i'm i'm wondering why didn't becker
notice this because
that's the being and time thing is it's
got to be now
right and then he says so okay so now
i've dealt
somewhat uh with the the
death part and now he says
now you've got to deal with what he
calls existential guilt
and he says well all right what you have
to
you have to realize that
like it or not you have to make choices
you know this is jean-paul sartre we are
condemned by virtue of consciousness
to choosing but heidegger is a little
bit more precise he's like
look as i was saying earlier
you're in reality you're an
insignificant speck of respiring
carbon-based dust borne into a time and
place not of your
choosing when you're here for a
microscopic amount of time
after which you are not
and for heidegger
you have to realize that
like i said i didn't choose to be born a
male or
jewish sure in america the offspring of
working class
people and heidegger what he says is
yeah but you still have to make choices
and accept responsibility for those
choices even though you didn't choose
any of the parameters that ultimately
limit what's available to you
and moreover you're going to not
always make good choices so now you're
you're guilty uh for your
choices and then he uses the the poet
uh he has a phrase becker uses it in the
denial of death
the guilt of unlived life i just
love that you have to accept
that you have already diminished
and in many ways amputated your own
possibilities
by virtue of choices that you've made or
just as often have declined to make
because you are reluctant to accept
responsibility
for uh for the opportunities
that you are now able to create
by virtue of seeing the possibilities
that lay before you
so anyway heidegger then says look okay
so uh you know i'm a professor
and i live in america in the 21st
century
well if i was in the third century
living in a yurt
in mongolia i'm not going to have an
opportunity
to be a professor but
what he submits is that there is some
aspects of whatever i am
that are independent of my cultural and
historical circumstances
in other words there is a me of sorts
heidegger would take vigorous issues so
would heidegger scholars
because i'm not claiming to understand
him this is my classic comic book
rendering
but heidegger's point is that you get to
the point where you're able to
say okay
i i am a contingent historical
and cultural artifact
but so what you know if i was uh you
know now if i was transported a thousand
years in the past
in asia i'd be in the same situation i
would still be conditioned
by time and place i would still have
choices
that i could make within the confines
of what opportunities are afforded to me
and then heidegger says if i can get
that
far in this is his language he says that
there is a transformation and he
literally he calls it a
turning you're turning away from a
flight from death
and you are allowed you therefore you
see
a horizon as his word of opportunity
that makes you
in a state of anticipatory resoluteness
with solicitous regard for others
that makes your life seem like an
adventure perfused with unshakable joy
all right let me unpack those things it
is beautiful it is i love lex that
you're resonating to the time
thing so he's like okay we already
talked about now
anticipatory is is already hopeful
because it's looking forward yeah right
to be
resolute it it means to be steadfast
and and to just have confidence in
um what you're doing moving forward
all right solicitous i had to look up
all these words by the way
it is it just means that uh you are
concerned about your fellow human beings
and but i love the idea
uh even if it seems allegorical i don't
mind that at all
this idea you said love earlier and i
think that
when heidegger is talking about being
solicitous
that's as close as he can get uh there's
an italian
yes uh sergeant trump so what was that
line again with the solicitors of that
okay now the whole thing if they're
turning away from death and then yeah
all the words you said are just
beautiful i love those words yeah
anticipatory
resoluteness that is accompanied with
solicitous regard to our fellow humans
which
makes life appear to us to be
an ongoing adventure that is
permeated by unshakeable joy
now again heidegger is not uh mary
poppins
this guy's got a tattoo uh no
that's not great i just love that exact
quote no
i'm piecing together these are his exact
words
that and i spent the last two years
reading almost everything
that i can find because i want to i'm
sick of death
you said it so i want to second what you
say lex
so it's not about death it's the
sherwood
anderson guy he's a novelist that i like
about
he wrote a book called winesburg ohio
and uh now i'm gonna forget what he said
on his tombstone
uh but you know it was something to the
effect oh he said
life not death is the great adventure
the the point being is that you know the
to consider that we must die
and the existential implications of that
really the goal the way i see it
is getting from hate to to love
yeah and i feel like heidegger
has a way of thinking about things that
moves us more in that direction
and so that's kind of my current
preoccupation is to take what i just
said to you and to talk about it
with my colleagues and other academic
psychologists because
the way we started with ernest becker
remember i said earlier i wasn't trained
in any of these things i'm an egghead
researcher that was doing experiments
about biofeedback
and you know then we read these becker
books and
i thought they were so interesting that
for the first few years we didn't have
any studies
i just would travel around and i'd be
like here's what this becker guy says i
think this is cool
well my my present view is i'm like
here's what this heidegger guy says
i i think these ideas
are consistent with what becker is
saying because they are anchored in
death
anxiety but i like that
direction as an alternative
to the kierkegaardian insistence
that the only psychologically tenable
way
to extricate ourselves uh from
uh maladaptive reactions to death
anxiety is through
faith in the traditional sense yeah i i
always kind of uh saw kierkegaard
unfairly like you said
in a comic book sense uh of the word
faith as a non-traditional sense i kind
of like the idea of leap of faith oh i
love that idea
and so what i've been battling about
with you know kierkegaard or
heidegger you know i'm like yeah
kierkegaard is a leap of faith
in god heidegger is a leap of faith
in life and i i just yeah i like it
you